avec son puissant goût de poisson et de
sel l'anchois et le roi des mal-aimés
pourtant il règne dans la cuisine
méditerranéenne
salut
est importatrice d'un choix c'est amené
les anchois aujourd'hui elle fait
découvrir de nouveaux produits à son ami
Ariel chef au restaurant Beba que ce
sont entières oui ok merci dans d'autres
pays ça fait partie vraiment de la
culture de l'histoire mais on est en
train de le redécouvrir si on veut ici
c'est quelque chose qui amène rapidement
du goût du en particulier de loumami
c'est sûr que si on utilise une anchois
qui est plus de qualité on va plus
l'apprécier que sur mon choix vous
prenez vous un choix pas comme trop cher
parce que c'est plus pour rehausser
exactement
amoureux de ce petit poisson Ariel en
propose toujours sur son menu
aujourd'hui il prépare une salsa verde à
base d'anchois
je commence avec un petit peu de 4 je
vais ajouter des filets des anchois
après ça le persil
finalement le citron c'est pour apporter
la dose de
fraîcheurder donc plus vinaigrette à
l'européenne exactement et pour servir
ça on va couper avec des œufs c'est
vraiment simple
comme l'anchois est un poisson très
périssable il est rare de le trouver
frais sur les étals de poissonnier il
est donc le plus souvent proposé en pot
en boîte ou en conserve entier ou en
filet dans l'huile ou le sel
tout ce qu'on trouve dans l'huile sur un
poisson avec peu d'arêtes on peut le
manger tel quel il y a aucune autre
préparation à faire en tant que
consommateur si on ouvre des anchois au
sel il faut absolument les tremper les
rincées les anchois marinés dans le
vinaigre n'ont pas la même apparence que
ceux dans l'huile c'est la même façon
travailler de deux façons différentes
c'est le vinaigre qui les rend blanc
quand il a cette couleur là on sait
qu'il a été préservé au vinaigre et si
les Archos sont bruns donc c'est un
travail au sel et après ça mis en huile
l'anchois est un des poissons les plus
riches en oméga 3 il contient également
du fer une grande quantité de calcium et
de vitamine D le choix en épicerie c'est
grandement amélioré ces dernières années
il y en a pour tous les goûts et tous
les portefeuilles on peut payer aussi
peu que 4 dollars le 100 g mais ça c'est
le classique bien des gens connaissent
un peu âpre salé mais pas trop quand
même je dirais que c'est agréable je
pense pas que beaucoup de personnes le
mangeraient tel quel mais ce serait
excellent justement dans des
vinaigrettes ou dans des sauces mais on
peut payer aussi jusqu'à 40 dollars le
100 g les anchoises de cantabris sont
souvent reconnues comme les meilleurs
qu'on peut trouver
les enchères sont empêchés juste au nord
de la région de cantabris où les eaux
sont très très froides c'est à dire que
les anchois qui sont dans ces eaux là
ont beaucoup plus de gras que d'autres
choix qu'on trouve ailleurs on a un
filet qui est exceptionnellement grand
et ferme donc une texture aussi qui
dérivée justement de ces conditions de
l'eau les anchois de cantabris aussi il
y a différentes catégories donc le 00
c'est vraiment pour indiquer la
meilleure qualité qu'on peut trouver
c'est d'ailleurs pour mettre en valeur
ces anchois de quant à Brie carrière
nous cuisine une tarte à la pomme de
terre
avec les oignons caramélisés
c'est comme une pâte brisée avec un
petit peu de sucre pour balancer la
salinité des anchois après ça nous avons
des pommes de terre rates qui sont
cuites coupez bien mince
[Rires]
[Musique]
que je vais répéter ça c'est assuré
maintenant cette
[Musique]
c'est bon
le mélange de moi avec les anchois là le
côté sucré de la pomme de terre et merci
beaucoup d'avoir cuisiné les beaux plats
avec les anchois
[Musique]